you know what I'd like to be I mean if I
had my goddamn choice what stop swearing
you know that song if a body catch a
body coming through the Rye
I'd like its if a body meet a body
coming through the Rye old Phoebe said
it's a poem by Robert Burns I know it's
a poem by Robert Burns
she was right though it is if a body
meet a body coming through the Rye I
didn't know it then though I thought it
was if a body catch a body I said anyway
I keep picturing all these little kids
playing some game in this big field of
rye and all thousands of little kids and
nobody's around nobody big I mean except
me and I'm standing on the edge of some
crazy cliff what I have to do I have to
catch everybody if they start to go over
the cliff I mean if they're running and
they don't look where they're going I
have to come out from somewhere and
catch them that's all I do all day I'd
just be the Catcher in the Rye '''l I
know it's crazy but that's the only
thing I'd really like to be I know it's
crazy
it wasn't crazy and that's what you were
for millions of us thank you rest in
peace
you